in our last episode we covered the best
practices for deploying and using cloud
operations in an enterprise environment
but we still left some questions
unanswered how should you monitor your
services
how should you deal with alerts and what
about managing cost
today we'll look at best practices that
you can use to get the most value out of
cloud monitoring
welcome to engineering for reliability
with google cloud
just like last time let's first figure
out why monitoring is important at all
what are we trying to achieve when we
use cloud monitoring we're after three
main objectives in parallel our first
objective is to keep our users happy
that means we need to know whether our
services is meeting their needs and the
best way to do that is through
well-defined slos and error budgets and
alerts that let us know when our service
is burning error budget
our second objective is to be able to
quickly and effectively respond when
those alerts do fire
this means having enough data about the
state of our service to be able to
triage incidents identify effective
mitigations and accurately confirm the
effectiveness of those mitigations
our final goal is to do the first two
while managing the associated costs now
that we've covered the whys let's turn
to the house
we'll start by talking about what to
monitor
from there we'll get into how to best
manage alerts and finally we'll cover
cost management for cloud monitoring
let's get into it
let's start by talking about the obvious
first question what should you be
monitoring
for the answer we can turn to chapter 6
of the site reliability engineering book
on monitoring distributed systems
fundamentally the objective of
monitoring is to answer two questions
the first one is all about symptoms
what are our users experiencing and is
that experience in any way less than
ideal
the second question is all about causes
what's causing the symptoms we've
identified that cause may be direct or
intermediate but it's how we start to
determine how to restore user experience
back to the desired state if it's
degraded in some way
we answer the first question by clearly
defining our service identifying good
service level indicators or slis that
tell us as accurately as possible how
well our service is able to meet our
users expectations
and defining good service level
objectives or slos that set a target
that our slis have to meet
we've covered defining services of slis
and slos and cloud monitoring
extensively in the series but it's
always worth revisiting these topics the
first answer to the question of what
should we monitor is how well is your
service meeting the needs of your users
as expressed by good slos
the next thing to make sure your
monitoring covers is what the sre book
refers to as the golden signals
traffic is essentially a measure of how
much user activity the service is
responding to usually as a count of
incoming requests for user facing
services or data elements for data
pipelines
error rate is a measure of what
percentage of the time the user activity
is not successful which of course
depends on the service and user
expectations
latency is a measure of how long the
service takes to service a request
and finally saturation is a measure of
how much of the available capacity the
service is using at a given time
a great way to ensure that you have easy
access to these signals is to create a
dashboard like this
it shows the four golden signals for a
given service at once it makes it easy
to correlate for example increases in
inbound traffic to latency degradations
or increased capacity requirements you
can automate the creation of dashboards
like this for your services we'll link
to some examples in the episode notes
finally you may need to augment your
monitoring with custom telemetry to
capture service specific information we
covered doing this in the previous
episode review that for an introduction
to instrumenting your services with open
senses and prometheus
so that takes care of the first question
what you should be monitoring we've just
covered slos golden signals and custom
telemetry which brings us to alerting
how should you configure alerts what
should you alert on and how should you
respond to alerts let's take a look
let's again return to the monitoring
chapter of the sre book these four
criteria should be applied to alerts
that go to pagers
every time the pager goes off we should
be able to react with a sense of urgency
but we can only react with a sense of
urgency a few times a day before we
become fatigued
every page should be actionable
every page response should require
intelligence if a page merits only a
robotic response it shouldn't be a page
and ideally pages alert us about a novel
problem or an event that hasn't been
seen before that means we need to take
action to prevent pages from reoccurring
once we've mitigated the triggering
condition and hopefully identify the
root cause
alerts that don't meet these criteria
should not be pages alerts that aren't
actionable are of no use at all alerts
that require human intervention but that
aren't urgent should be filed as tickets
instead
cloud monitoring supports multiple
notification channels and this allows
you to set up alert delivery that meets
your needs for example you could use
email or pager duty delivery to trigger
pagers and configure a webhook or prop
sub-integration to file tickets for
non-urgent dollars
you can also automate the management of
your alerts by using an automation tool
like terraform this helps to ensure
consistency and avoids human errors in
alert configuration
finally it's important to understand the
tools you have available to capture and
optimize your monitoring costs let's
have a look at those now
first it's important to understand how
you incur monitoring costs platform
metrics emitted by google cloud services
are always free you are charged for
other metrics such as custom metrics or
those written by istio based on storage
volume refer to the pricing page for the
latest version of this information
the monitoring settings page shows you
exactly how much data you are ingesting
for each project in your metric scope
you can measure your usage by using
billing reports and filtering them to
just the monitoring service to see
exactly how much monitoring charges
you're incurring in your project
you can even figure out exactly how much
data is being ingested by each custom
metric by creating a chart and using the
metric bytes adjusted metric
these tools do a great job of helping
you understand the sources of monitoring
costs but what can you do to optimize
those let's have a look
the way that you use labels for cloud
components might impact the volume of
time series that are generated for your
metrics and monitoring
for example you can use labels to
appropriately report metrics to cost
centers on your bill and to signify
whether specific environments are
production or development
adding these labels means that
additional time series are generated in
monitoring you can calculate the total
number of time series by multiplying the
cardinality of all labels
for example if there are 11 cost center
values and 5 environment values that
means 55 time series are generated this
is why the way that you add labels might
add significant metric volume and
therefore increase the cost
we recommend carefully limiting the
number of labels and avoiding label
values with high cardinality
metric sent from the cloud apps agent
are another source of monitoring costs
the agent collects app and system
metrics from common third-party apps and
additional vm level metrics
if you don't need them for certain vms
you can reduce the volume by not sending
these metrics you can also reduce the
metric values by reducing the number of
vms that use the agent
custom metrics are chargeable metrics
created by using the monitoring api or
integrations like opencensus to monitor
any metrics that are user instruments
the more services that you instrument to
send metrics the more custom monitoring
metrics are generated
if you want to reduce metric volumes you
can reduce the number of custom
monitoring metrics that your services
send
thanks for joining me today we covered
best practices for setting up and using
cloud monitoring including what to
monitor how to manage alerts and how to
optimize your monitoring costs i hope
these recommendations help you keep your
users happy in our next episode we'll
tackle best practices for using cloud
logging thanks so much for watching
today don't forget to like and subscribe
to never miss out on more engineering
for reliability with google cloud see
you soon
you